et maintenant
jean marie vidal
bonsoir jean marc et moi ça va je vais
super bien j'ai jamais été aussi bien de
ma vie jean marais ça fait trois jours
que tu allais même polo mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fout fatima et binche et ben non
messieurs ce que tu vois je il porte le
même nom mais il est sale
non non non non non il va bien j'aime
bien j'aime bien rester en pyjama tout
le temps tu mets du temps les mêmes
fringues tout le temps avec moi je
change quand même c'est les mêmes du
change oui moi aussi je changerais
combien de t-shirts de bandol en noir et
blanc cinquantaine ouais pourquoi 50
parce que tu es la femme de ménage elle
vient que tous les deux mois voilà il
mardi dernier en vue au stade de france
les dégâts les essais pour votre
division elle et ses monumentales
j'ai quand même demandé j'ai dit tiens
il faudrait vingt mille personnes pour
faire un essai à grammy personnes qui
sont venues déjà toi c'est déjà les gens
sont cons déjà non mais tu dois y aller
très bien car ait pu dire où il faisait
ses deux sont d'accord
tu vois il ya donc j'ai des copains
chanteurs chanteuses et qui sont venus
et entre les chansons on a parlé on a
fait le con avec mon laurent avec
françois rollin ce qu'il était mais
envoyés spéciaux dans le stade et on a
constaté presqu'immédiatement que ça
m'affiche thème en place marche mais
d'une manière incroyable quoi maintenant
je suis un autre homme parce que j'ai
plus qu'à la sueur et la cei 18 je suis
rassuré nucléaire à 50 mille personnes
là dedans ça va être un truc formidable
on est obligé de prévenir l'aviation
civile pourquoi ben parce que tu vois le
fard qu'il y a un goût de la tour eiffel
il y en a 44 dans le stade
toi c'est des trucs de trois mètres de
diamètre qui vont balayer le ciel et
gand vers un chapeau de lumière sur le
stade de france j'y tiens c'est ce qu'on
va faire on va prendre l'image satellite
c'est qu'un site qui te donne des images
qui doit brand par le satellite l'image
de paris avec un gâteau à côté de paris
qui sera le stade de france et on va re
projetés ça dans les écrans des mesures
et veulent à dire voilà ce que ça donne
vue du satellite ces normes 400
automatique une
la facette de 10 mètres de diamètre
maintenant tu as je le dis avec la
banane parce que je chie dans mon froc
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours
rappelons qu'amy de sonde sur mars
derrière des gens à 100 à 150 bornes de
paris on va voir ce chapiteau de lumière
et des gens qui vont regarder ça de
strasbourg de leurs balcons tutorial est
alors finalement dentelle marché à
strasbourg pour que l'on peut regarder
une loupiote jean-marie skis